Speaker 1: Well, Donald Trump's brain appears
to have been broken by Ron DeSantis.
Trump is now posting daily to truth central
about it.
Truth.
Central.
Yeah.
Truth.
Truth, social.
Now I'm calling it the wrong thing.
Truth.
Social.
Yes.
Not truth central.
You know, a few days ago, Donald Trump said
he never thinks about Ron DeSantis.
And that made me think that all Trump is thinking
about is Ron DeSantis.
And Trump is now just posting daily about
DeSantis.
Trump is obsessed with a guy who hasn't actually
announced that he's running against Trump
yet.
Let's take a look at a couple of these posts
every day.
It is something.
Here is one from a couple of days ago.
Donald Trump posting, quote, so interesting
to watch Fox News cover the small and unenthusiastic
139 person crowd in Staten Island for DeSantis.
But stay as far away as possible from coverage
of the thousands of people, many unable to
get in at the Club 47 event in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
I call Fox News the Reno Network, and they're
down.
Big ratings accurately reflect the name.
If fake news CNN was smart, which they're
not, they'd go conservative and all Trump
all the time, like in 2016 and become a Capital
R ratings capital J juggernaut.
There are like ten fascinating things about
this post, and you have to understand the
context and kind of be aware of the back story
on a lot of these things.
First and foremost, Trump's continued obsession
with crowds.
DeSantis had 139 people.
I had thousands.
Fox News is talking about that crowd.
They're not talking about my crowd.
That's bad.
Secondly, anything short of complete brown
nosing and sucking up to Trump immediately
gets you branded a RINO.
If you're a Republican who is anything other
than completely and unflinchingly and blindly
loyal to Trump, you're a RINO.
If you are a network and you cover what a
different Republican did instead of what Trump
did, you are a RINO.
And then lastly, again, Trump's idea.
He's mentioned this a number of times now
that CNN could really do something stunning
if they were to become conservative like Fox,
that everybody would flock to CNN even after
Trump has been bashing CNN for the greater
part of a decade at this point in time.
And he's probably right.
I mean, the truth is, if CNN became conservative
and Trump said CNN is the place to go, I'm
sure that his followers who have spent years
talking about how CNN is some kind of Marxist
satanic influence on American society, I'm
sure they would just go over there again.
Remember, Trump told us he's not thinking
about Ron DeSantis, but he is posting about
Ron DeSantis every single day, sent his next
post, quote, Florida was doing great long
before Ron DeSantis got there.
People are fleeing.
By the way, The Sanctus is really funny.
I know that what took first it was this sanctimonious,
but I don't know if to say this is a is a
typo of Trump's nickname for the Sanders or
it's the next evolution.
But there is something funny about that.
Okay.
People are fleeing from New York to Florida
and other places because of high taxes and
out of control crime, not because of governor.
Thank you.
President Trump, too sanctimonious.
Rick Scott did great and even Charlie Crist
had very good numbers.
Sunshine and ocean, very alluring.
So I think the point Trump is trying to make
here is Florida is great, but it has nothing
to do with desanctis.
It's great because of the sunshine and the
ocean and the, you know, low, no state income
tax and all this stuff.
Speaking of the taxes and this is a tangent,
but I believe it's an appropriate one, if
you will allow it.
When I talked last week about.
Oh, my.
Moving to Florida.
And I said, Well, I'm not moving to Florida,
but it is seeming pretty appealing to spend
like January and February in Florida and avoid
some of the Northeast, you know, gray dark
winters or whatever.
Some people wrote in saying, David, I know
you're really talking about that because you
want to pay no state income tax.
Now, the truth is, if you live for two months
in Florida, you know, these northern states,
New York, Connecticut, Massachusetts, they
don't let you stop paying income tax.
I believe that you have to spend like more
at least more than half of the year in order
to be able to say, I live in Florida.
But then other people wrote to me and said,
David, if you're actually thinking about the
Florida thing because you want to avoid state
income tax, they get you in other ways because
property taxes are very high and other taxes
are.
And all these things that I don't even know
if that's true, it's totally plausible to
me that maybe it's not actually cheaper tax
wise to live in Florida because you save on
state income, but you pay.
I don't even know.
I have not looked into it, but it wouldn't
shock me if that were true.
As far as Desanctis Ron DeSantis isn't even
running and Trump is posting daily about him.
Just imagine what the next year is going to
be like if DeSantis does run, and it appears
as though he is gearing up
for that.